would you rather have teeth where your  hair is  where the [ __ ] is that eyebrows or hair  where your teeth are  would you have to comb your teeth after  every meal  yeah yeah yeah seemed like you would  that's a good question  you'd have to call comb yeah like brush  your hair after every meal  yeah eating would be a yeah but you know  what i bet no wouldn't because you ever  get food in your hair right so it's a  good thing it's easy to get out and if  your teeth were hair  it's like built-in floss but then so  then the other choice would i rather  have teeth  i'd rather cornrows but like teeth oh  just here like here yeah  what side would you part your teeth i  would go with the middle part oh like  letterman  i like that i want a big space i want a  gap i want a gap here i'm going to do  that you know what if you had hair if  you had teeth where your hair there'd be  no reason to do that  [Music]  oh and it gets something out of your  tooth there's something in my tooth